another Mario game this year my god how
many of those are we gonna have and how
many am I gonna talk about but this is
for a new system so that's cool new
Super Mario Brothers again or new super
mario brothers you this was called so
new super mario brothers you is the new
new Super Mario Brothers for the Wii U
you say that three times fast
I'm impressed don't type it cuz that's
not impressive why are you going to your
keyboard to type it right now I just sit
nevermind so a new super mario brothers
you it's the same stick as before
Bowser's kidnapped the princess so now
he has all those little Koopa kids and
they're all in their castles and you go
through all the worlds and you take them
all out literally this same as before
although before you had a lot of coins
and it was absurdly easy this time
around less coins and it's actually it's
more challenging what I liked about New
Super Mario Brothers use it goes back to
the whole overhead view world system all
the worlds are connected it's not like
they're isolated things so it feels a
lot like Super Mario World I really like
that it's a small thing it doesn't
affect the gameplay at all but you look
at it and you're like hearken back to
the old school that's cool and you have
a new powerup you get this acorn that
gives you pretty much a flying squirrel
suit and the flying squirrel suit lets
you glide through the air but you know
you're slowly going down I wish it was
like the Super Mario Cape in Super Mario
World where you push back on the d-pad
you can go up and ultimately glide
through pretty much the entire level I
thought that was a really cool cape it
was a really cool power I missed that
that being said the flying squirrel
suits pretty cool then you get hit by a
stupid Chain Chomp or something and you
lose it you're like well I didn't really
get the fidgets with that that much and
like I said this games actually a bit
challenging there was one level where it
took 10 lives to get through it granted
get through it and get all the coins but
still attend lives I haven't spent 10
lives in the Super Mario level in years
and what's really cool is you can post
messages through the miiverse for other
players I died trying to get this one
coin this message came up from some user
he was like yeah that first coins a pain
in the ass so when I beat the level it
was like do you want to leave any advice
for people playing this level I just
type try not to throw your controller
good advice if I do say so myself but my
main gripe and the recent super mario
games is that these games are really
easy they're made for kids granted
they've always been made for kids but I
feel like they were harder back in the
day new super mario brothers you
actually has challenging levels I love
that it's like Nintendo listen to
feedback that or they were like alright
we had our B squad working on the other
Super Mario games
this is where the a squad was working on
new Super Mario Brothers you now that
being said this game as a launch title
to a new system isn't really innovative
at all I don't know about you but I was
hoping for the next Mario 64 or Mario
Galaxy for the Wii U you know their new
system it had to have something really
cool and innovative this one's a side
scroller Mario game
now it's like the umpteenth installment
of a size scroller Mario game is
starting to lose currency you know what
I mean I mean yeah someone can have the
Wiimote and be playing the game another
player can have the Wii U pad and start
pushing the pad and creating blocks for
Mario to step on to get items and coins
and whatnot that or he can be a dick and
put a platform above Mario's head as he
tries to jump over a pit and kill him
that's what people will do with it it's
I'm just saying that's really the only
way you mechanic it uses it's really
cool to be able to turn off your TV and
then actually play the game with the Wii
U pad that's really a Wii U function in
general not something for the game it's
cool seeing Mario and HD that's never a
bad thing it's you're like wow these
graphics these are graphics never seen
in a Mario game that being said does
that add to the gameplay no it's safe I
guess that's my thing about it if this
was a talent show competition on TV or
something that's what the judges would
be like it's safe it's enough to get you
to the next round but the next round you
really got to step it up Nintendo has to
step up there Mario game in the next one
and give us something really monumental
you know the Mario game of that decade
otherwise people are really gonna stop
giving a [ __ ] they'll always play them
but their casual play fun games like all
right yeah I got I need a time burner
let's play this side scroller Mario game
time burner new super mario brothers you
does have these really cool challenges
like alright fly through the entire
level in the allotted time get through
the level while never touching the
ground you have to keep hopping on
turtle shells and whatnot it's like the
challenge Tower and Mortal Kombat but
for Mario I thought that was really cool
challenge just like that just kind of
give a lot of replay value to a game
like this or any game in general all in
all new Super Mario Brothers you should
just be called Super Mario Brothers you
at this point the side scroller Mario
games are not new anymore it's more
challenging that's awesome it has really
cool challenges that's fun but it's not
the groundbreaking innovative Mario
title you would want for a launch title
for a new Nintendo system I will say new
super mario brothers you is worth buying
at full price for sure it's a safe bet
you'll have fun playing it no one's
gonna drop 60 bucks on this game be like
I regret and hate every second of that
they're fun games you know you give him
credit words do that being said next
time Nintendo seriously give us like
more
galaxy 3 or something that'd be awesome
but anything is the Wii U everyone's
like oh if you didn't preorder it you're
not getting it so I stood outside a Fred
Meyer for like six hours I was freezing
my nuts off I had a scarf on and I got
it at midnight now they're everywhere
I'm like okay that's the last time I
freeze my sack off for a game system
ever in my life stupid me I'm still
living in the 90s that's the thing so
the Wii U have you played it and if you
have what's the launch game that you got
with it whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]